thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
these were the sort of the pro-democracy
Egyptians they were people who either
voted for Morsi or who didn't want to
see a military takeover and many of
those people hit the streets they
protested all across Egypt
[Music]
he was repeatedly saying in his speeches
and in his interviews that the Egyptian
Nation wanted him to step in and remove
Muhammad Morsi so the fact that there
was opposition in the streets was a
really uh just sort of a black eye on
the military regime at that time
[Music]
foreign
was from the perspective of the CC
regime untenable it could not go on any
longer and they made the decision that
they were going to use Force and and
obviously the decision was made to kill
to kill many many people
[Music]
Egypt continues to score very low on on
all the human rights measures there are
tens of thousands of people
languishing in Egyptian prisons
Draconian legislation has been passed
over the past seven or eight years
torture is rampant in in Egyptian
prisons as has been documented by
Amnesty International and Human Rights
Watch and other groups
[Music]
the robot Massacre sort of represented
the death of Egyptian politics there was
a brief period a brief opening in 2011
20 in 2012 and into 2013 where there was
legitimate uh political discourse there
was legitimate Fair political
competition you had dozens of political
parties you had free and fair elections
parliamentary presidential and other and
the rabba massacre ended all of that
[Music]